Frühstück ist die schönste Mahlzeit des
Tages ich meine was gibt es besseres als
am Wochenende auszuschlafen und entweder
schön frühstücken zu gehen oder sich was
richtig feines zu Hause zuzubereiten ich
weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist habt ihr
vielleicht dieses klassische
Sonntagsfrühstück mit Brötchen
Aufschnitt allem drum und dran oder
macht ihr euch vielleicht gerne ein
bisschen was aufwendigeres ich möchte
euch heute auf jeden Fall zeigen was
mein absolutes Lieblingsfrühstück ist
ich würde sagen legen wir einfach los
hier ist alles was ich für meinen
perfektes Sonntagsfrühstück brauche
zuallererst einmal ein paar Orangen ein
schöner frisch gepresster Orangensaft
finde ich vergoldet jeden Morgen dazu
gibt es heute ein eckdrop Sandwich ein
Sandwich bei dem ich vollkommen hängen
geblieben bin für Sandwiches aus
Südkorea aber mittlerweile haben die
ihren Weg nach Berlin gefunden vor allem
nach Berlin aber in anderen Großstädten
findet man sie auch so allmählich hier
in Köln gibt es noch kein gutes deshalb
ist es wie so oft wenn man es richtig
haben will muss man selbst machen das
Ganze machen wir mit Bacon den ich
richtig schön knusprig im Backofen
backen werde das auch ein kleiner Trick
mit dem man ihn jedes Mal perfekt Geld
bekommt den Bacon habe ich ein bisschen
dicker schneiden lassen als man ihn im
Supermarkt bekommt also einfach an der
frische Theke und habe in der schneiden
lassen dazu machen wir ein Soft Scram
berührei auch wieder eine Sache wo man
den ein oder anderen Trick anwenden kann
um am Ende dieses perfekte fluffige
herzhafte Frühstück Sandwich zu bekommen
ein Kaffee darf bei mir auch nicht
fehlen in letzter Zeit gab es viel zu
wenig Kaffee Content bei mir auf dem
Kanal wir machen jetzt zuallerletzt
dafür schöne kalte Milch aber fangen wir
erstmal an mit dem Bacon und mein Bacon
werde ich direkt ohne Backpapier auf
diesem metallenden Backblech ausbreiten
jetzt gebe ich das ganze in den Backofen
ja noch nicht vorgeheizt ist einfach 200
Grad ober Unterhitze einfach ein Auge
drauf haben sollte so 15 Minuten dauern
bis der goldbraun knusprig ist und die
perfekte Form hat vor allem für unsere
Sandwich während unser Bacon im Ofen
ready wird kümmern wir uns um unseren
frisch gepressten Orangensaft ich habe
hier so eine Saftpresse ist ein bisschen
unnötig also man kann die auch mit
Handpressen oder mit einer Handpresse
überhaupt kein Problem gibt's für 5 € im
Supermarkt das Ding hier nimmt ein
bisschen Arbeit ab
einmal halbieren Glas drunter und drauf
drücken ich erkläre jetzt gerade wie man
sagt wie man saftpresst aber ohne Witz
ein frisch gepresster Orangensaft so das
ist schon seit meiner Kindheit an das
ist einfach Sonntag das ist Frühstück
das ist entspannt das ist einfach geil
und jetzt wo ich über meinen perfektes
Frühstück nachgedacht habe durfte das
auf jeden Fall nicht fehlen Jay ist
gepresst einen ersten Stück gönne ich
mir schon mal es ist einfach schöne
frühstücken kann somit das beste der
Welt sein wenn man so auf ganz entspannt
sich einfach Zeit nimmt was leckeres
zubereitet ich glaube unser Bacon sieht
langsam echt gut aus seht euch das
einfach mal an eine sehr sehr schöne
Form von beiden Seiten wird der
gleichmäßig wenn wir ihn jetzt noch auf
Zewa legen dann kriegt er auch die
Knusprigkeit die er verdient hat aber
wir haben jetzt schon so eine etwas
dickere Textur und die Farbe sieht
eigentlich echt gut aus deshalb holen
ihn raus er ist ja schon draußen stellen
wir Ihnen auf Zimmer kümmern wir uns
jetzt um unser Brioche ich habe zwei
verschiedene Varianten der Idealfall ist
ihr habt einen Brioche an einem Stück
das ist aber un
immer schwer zu bekommen denn das hier
war die einzige Hälfte Brioche die ist
gerade in Köln zu kaufen gibt wir waren
bei zehn verschiedenen Bäckereien wir
wollten nämlich eigentlich so ein
schönes großes früheres wie dieses das
hier ist aus dem Supermarkt aber halt im
ganzen weil das ist schon geschnitten an
und für sich machen wir nämlich genau
folgendes wir schneiden uns etwas
dickere Scheiben von unserem Brioche
runter so dass wir es dann von beiden
Seiten anrösten können in der Mitte
halbieren und dann perfekt auffüllen
können wenn wir zwei einzelne Scheiben
haben dann hält natürlich unten nicht
zusammen aber ich zeige euch auch mal
mit diesem Brioche weil es schmeckt
natürlich am Ende genauso gut und das
werdet ihr bedeutend einfacher bekommen
kann hier drüben sollte es langsam heiß
sein ist es auch das heißt wir nehmen
uns ein wenig Butter im Brioche ist zwar
schon Butter drin aber wir gucken nicht
auf die Kalorien und schmelzen die ein
bisschen die Stellen jetzt sicher dass
die Butter schön einzieht und wie eine
gute Kontaktfläche haben und jetzt
warten wir bis das ganze dann so
aussieht eine wunderschöne gleichmäßige
Bräunung jetzt ist die andere Seite noch
dran und ich sage euch so viel das
Brioche
ist ein Traum guckt euch mal an wie viel
Fett die aus dem Bacon rauskommt es ist
ohne das ganze Fett ist quasi wirklich
eine sehr gesunde Speise die man sich da
morgens mal rein gönnen kann deswegen
auch das Zewa das saugt das gesamte Fett
dann auch auf genau und so ist es
bleiben nur noch Proteine Vitamine übrig
deshalb sehr empfehlenswert auch für
jeden der eine Sport Ernährung fährt
auch hinlegen abkühlen lassen das Pferd
sieht raus und am Ende erhalten wir
schön knusprigen Bacon wie man ihn nur
aus Amerika kennt unser Bacon ist jetzt
langsam hier schon getrocknet und kriegt
dann auch die Form so wie er sagt die
haben soll grad schon mal einen kleinen
Qualitätszeit macht schmeckt auch sehr
sehr gut die Pfanne wird heiß wir machen
soft scrambit x Pfanne warm werden
lassen dann haue ich einfach mal fünf
sechs Eier rein pro Sandwich denke ich
reichen zwei drei
wenn euch meine Schale ins Ei rein fällt
dann holt sie einfach mit der Schale
wieder raus weil dann glitcht die nicht
so runter das ist ein guter Dreck auf
jeden Fall heute auch mal ein paar
lifehacks sollte man ein bisschen mehr
Zeit entspannter Sonntag Morgen als ihr
jetzt gerade das Video seht und noch im
Bett seid nach einem langen Samstagabend
geht nicht einkaufen weil ihr könnt ihr
nicht einkaufen gehen das nachmachen
einfach eine Prise Salz dazu so Eiern
und dann kommt der wichtigste Test den
wir für unsere soft Scram mit Rührei
machen können ist wie die Butter schmilz
wenn ihr sie in die Pfanne gibt die
sollte nämlich schon relativ schnell
runter schmelzen so dass man die Pfanne
mit der Butter ein bisschen abkühlt die
Pfanne gleichmäßig mit Butter bedeckt
ist aber sie soll auch nicht verbrennen
direkt braun werden sondern ziemlich
genau so wie es jetzt ist soll das Ganze
aussehen hat jetzt 5 Sekunden gedauert
die Butter ist geschmolzen das heißt wir
können das Ei hineingeben eingeben wir
einfach rein hört auf dieses leichte
köchelnde Geräusche und dann fangen wir
einfach direkt an das Ei zu bewegen und
hören auch nicht auf bis wir die
perfekte Konsistenz erreicht haben
Temperaturkontrolle ist auf jeden Fall
der Key und auch dass man das Ei ein
bisschen vorher vom Herd runterzieht
weil die Pfanne hat ja noch Hitze wenn
ihr ein E oder Gasherd habt dann zieht
auf jeden Fall die Pfanne vom Kochfeld
runter langsam erreichen wir die
perfekte Konsistenz und ich habe viele
Rezepte gesehen die dann irgendwie noch
Creme fraiche Schlagsahne sonst was
hinzufügen das hier ist einfach nur Ei
that's it und ich finde das ist perfekt
bisschen Pfeffer noch dazu noch ein
letztes Mal durchrühren es könnte noch
ein bisschen gebrauchen aber ich nehme
es jetzt runter von der Hitze weil ihr
seht ja da ist noch ordentlich
Temperatur da und das stockt noch ein
bisschen nach eine Soße braucht das
ganze auch ich mache einfach das Rad
schon Mario aus Mario da könnt ihr mal
raten was die andere Zutat ist nicht
irgendeine Mario cupy Mario japanische
wirklich
gamechanger wer sie kennt weiß Bescheid
Marion
Verhältnis je nachdem wie man die
Schärfe will ich mache immer ungefähr
1:1 oder einfach nach Gefühl jetzt
passiert die Magie jetzt wird aus rot
und weiß orange
sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen das Ei
stand jetzt noch ein bisschen jetzt hat
es allmählich die perfekte Konsistenz
aber wie gesagt das ist nicht mehr auf
der Hitze deshalb bisschen
vorausschauend handeln so Freunde es ist
langsam soweit wir können unser brioch
nehmen jetzt kann nämlich alles schief
gehen dieses Brioche sollten wir nur bis
ungefähr hierhin schneiden so dass wir
es aufklappen können ohne dass es uns
auseinanderbricht es ist ein echten eine
fehleranfällige Geschichte lieber zu
wenig als zu viel aufschneiden es
klappen wir das ganze auf und geben
unsere
Mayo einfach auf die Innenseite
ausstreichen genießen fertig dann kommt
eine Scheibe Sandwich Käse hinein der
schmilzt gleich noch mal ein bisschen
von unserem Rührei soll ich noch einen
zweiten machen oder reicht uns eine
immer eigentlich immer besser zeigen
machen wir oben auch noch eine rein
selbst und jetzt kommt unser Rührei
deshalb nennt man es auch echt Drop das
Eibe quasi einfach
hineinfallen gelassen und allmählich
kommt hier alles zusammen denn es fehlt
nur noch unser Bacon den wir auch schön
unten reinstopfen in die Tasche und
unser Brötchen anbietet leute das ist
wirklich ein Traum noch ein bisschen
mehr reinkommt zack zack zack tut euch
das an unten perfekt verschlossen vorne
cremiges Rührei knuspriger Bacon
schmelzener Käse und eine Sache fehlt
noch fürs Auge ein bisschen Schnittlauch
[Musik]
hier haben wir unsere Brioche Sandwiches
ich habe jetzt einfach noch mal damit
ihr seht weil wie gesagt es ist
unfassbar schwer zu bekommen eine ganz
normale Scheibe Brioche wie man es in
jedem Supermarkt bekommt angetoastet
jetzt legen wir das auf ein Blatt
Brotpapier ich bauen eigentlich genauso
zusammen wie wir es gerade auch gemacht
haben sagt da geht das gleiche unten ein
bisschen Platz lassen und jetzt eben
unsere obere brothälfte einfach dazu es
verpacken wir das wie das Geschenk das
ist einmal von unten hoch dann die
Seiten rein nach unten umschlagen und
fertig ist unser Sandwich für das wir
nicht 10 Stunden nach einem verdammten
Brio suchen müssen ein bisschen mager
das ist auch sehr charakteristisch für
actroop aber auf dem Teller und eine
Sache fehlt mir noch und zwar ein Kaffee
[Musik]
so Freunde heute haben wir uns einfach
mal Zeit genommen für ein richtig
schönes Frühstück und ich muss sagen
wenn ich jetzt hier vor mir stehen habe
es ist ein absoluter Traum frisch
gepresster Orangensaft eckdrop Sandwich
und ein schöner Kaffee die drei
verschiedenen Varianten die wir hier
haben sind einmal die richtige actor
Variante bei der alles gut gegangen ist
hier drüben habe ich einen kleinen fail
da ist es eigentlich einfach
aufgebrochen es sieht halt traumhaft aus
nee trotzdem wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr schmackhaft ja und auch unsere
einfache Variante muss ich überhaupt
nicht verstecken finde ich einmal schön
umwickelt mit ein bisschen Papier dann
hält das Ganze zusammen und lass uns
bitte einfach probieren und Freunde der
geht auf euch
schön
macht bitte holpriger luftig und putzig
ist das Ganze besser kann man es nicht
beschreiben
es tut mir wirklich leid für alle die
gerade ohne was zu Essen vom Bildschirm
sitzen weil für mich ist das gerade ein
absoluter Traum Erik du musst bitte
einfach mal reinbeißen
ganz ehrlich das hat auch sein eigenes
Video verdient vielleicht könnt ihr euch
ein zwei Tricks mitnehmen wirklich gebt
mir das zum Frühstück und ich bin dein
bester Freund ein absoluter Traum ich
hoffe ihr hattet genauso viel Spaß bei
dem Video wie ich ich fand es
unglaublich lecker mach das ganze
unbedingt nach täglich auf dem Videos
und genießt euren Sonntag nächsten
Sonntag vielleicht mit dem schönen Edgar
Sandwich bis dahin macht's gut ciao